jacky un cocktail s'il vous plaît je
vous sers le préféré de ma première
femme monsieur pourquoi vous vous êtes
séparés c'est une histoire banale
monsieur ma femme ressembler à nicoletta
et tous mes amis me disaient c'est fou
ce que ta femme ressemble à nicoletta
j'étais moi je n'étais pas dû parce que
je savais que ça n'était pas nicoletta
tout va bien alors oui mais un matin je
les quitte et monsieur pourquoi elle
chantait faux
oui
je pense qu'ils soient décédés
sinon
cent ans
le gérant chila potier
il pensait
poker
quand je t'aime
thomas
aux âmes
hammami
à
aujourd'hui je te veux bien
et je retombe
ce cher
qui paraît
comme souvent
les chauffe eau
avec eux
il
mais je ne peux pas
[Applaudissements]
oh
obama
ma mère
maison
le chat
les chiens sans frais
ja
que jamais
dans ce village que j'aime
tous
tout jeu
[Musique]
je
là
ma mémoire
sow
omar
mais nous
on y a bon soir mosley alors cette
chanson mamy blue c'était en quelle
année 72 72 sais pas s'il ya finalement
renoncé il ya plus de 20 ans nous pose
ne sont pas rendus compte qu'il a
écrites sur ses berges heroes walemme
compositeur que la bicig éléments le
soleil et le même moteur pire de la
ligue à 840 version dans nos outils
qu'il a chanté cette chanson
moi je l'entends du même en turc oihana
huy hà nam oy oy en larmes aux yeux le
fait parce que j'étais numéro un turc
qui travaille j'y suis allé à la bombe
oui alors en plus que c'était un peu une
chanson sur mesure parce que tout le
monde dont ils étaient les jambes tout
le monde savait que c'est ta grand-mère
qui t'avait élevé alors quand tu as fait
mamy blue tooth mentir on lâche un peu
ennuyés parce que j'avais pas vu que
c'est bien de là nous est en train de le
faire et que je dire si j'étais un peu j
culture ouhlala je veux pas de cet ex
tama mais elle n'est pas encore morte
et elles peur que ça avec cette année
mais exactement qu'elle ait peur que
d'avoir l'impression que j'enterre
exactement donc j'ai dû préparer ma
grand'mère tu en donnes casey jones et
mamies finalement la chanson qui dit que
je faisais à toi ya un petit problème et
c'est rien c'est une chanson que c'est
ce que c'est faux chantier pour les eaux
alors elle a très bien pris et c'est
vrai que cette chanson
c'était ma plus grosse vente de 10 et
j'ai toujours pensé quelque part qu'il
m'était destinée du ragondin de cette
chanson j'en suis rien jugé bas non moi
je connais pas mais vendredi ça
m'intéresse pas c'est une norme vendus
j'ai déjà du mal à retenir mes impôts de
congé du peuple je sais que j'ai dû
vendre 800 me dit je ne sais pas mais
quand même c'était rapporter beaucoup
d'argent très peu pas j'avais un contrat
très faible c'est une chanson tu t en
pleine gloire à l'époque mais c'est pas
la période la plus heureuse de ta vie
parce que à l'époque tu te sentais un
peu un peu seul comme ça au milieu du
système du show-business étaient un peu
perdus non je suis beaucoup donné
beaucoup donné au système beaucoup
travaillé et plus je travaillais plus
j'avais la gorge
je me sentais sale con mais c'est dans
ma porte de ma chambre à coucher rire de
notre portée mais ma poupée et ça moi je
peux pas le supporter j'ai besoin de
convivialité
j'ai besoin de chaleur humaine j'ai
besoin de partager les choses que je
reprends avec mes copains avec avec les
liens avec mon conjoint ou un bon
maintenant avec mon enfance et la chance
d'en avoir un et je un jour j'ai craqué
je suis parti dans mon pays au bord du
léman
j'ai trouvé une petite ferme à vicence
et un peu d'altitude j'vais retaper et
dès que je pouvais tu as fait quoi bon
alors j'ai fait beaucoup d'écoles
j'ai très agitée beaucoup de collèges
j'ai même fait cinq six mois de bon
pasteur sans pasteur c'était à l'époque
les années 60 qu'il ne maison on mettait
des jeunes filles terrible mais c'est
pas tout à fait la maison de correction
c'était une congrégation religieuse dont
la maison mère était à angers elle avait
48 heures en france je ne sais pas ce
que c'est devenu maintenant et ça
subissait encore des lois un petit peu
pétainiste et enfin si tu vois ce que je
veux dire quand même mais c'est une
belle expérience quand on a eu la chance
de vivre
ce genre de micro société avec le saint
lô prend le sens de la hiérarchie on
prend le sens du capot on apprend
beaucoup
on apprend surtout avoir la liberté dans
sa tête on peu derrière des barreaux
être libre du rebelle pour
définitivement
moi je pense qu'il faut être bête 13h
c'est très important c'est quand même
très simple comment tu étais arrivé à la
chanson commence à vue
la chanson j'ai commencé très tôt dans
l'église de mon village quand j'avais 8
et d'années dans la chance dans mon
petit village savoyard
vous êtes très belle église tous très
belle acoustique et des sommes
fabuleuses et quand j'étais petite fille
je travaillais la musique que curé du
village parce que j'étais d'une façon
catholique j'étais enfant de marie
jeanne et ce tous les matins dans la
rigole je fleuris series aura l'air
d'être assez ma vie j'y tiens beaucoup
c'est une très belle enfance et ce
prêtre était un très bon musicien et je
préparais donc les cantiques pour les
messes de minuit
les messes de pâques le dimanche et dans
mon village
tout le monde a l'air la chorale étaient
des gens du village le charcutier le les
voisins et c'est vrai que vend très
longtemps jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans au
moins
j'ai cru que ça faisait partie quotidien
de la vie des gens la musique et la
chanson je crois que tout le monde
savait chanter et 7 ans au collège sur
le compte que des gens qui chantait faux
comme des patates c'est une belle
rencontre avec la musique en tous les
cas ça c'était avant et ça fait quoi
après alain une fois que la chanson dont
il ya eu des faits dont je me suis
succès mais justement qu'est ce qui
s'est passé après après quoi enfin un
enfant tu as vu dans l'équipe et j'ai
marqué et en 77 67 g alexandre en mai
soit 119 g vous vraiment vivre ma
grossesse ou des débuts j'ai donc
vraiment je voulais que mon fils me dit
maman à moi et puis voir ses premiers
pas en tant de ses premiers rires parce
que ça voudrait pas qu'on me vole c'est
très important quand on décide des
maires il faut devenir bien sûr c'est un
choix primordial le problème c'est
qu'après quand tu as voulu revenir dans
le métier est aperçu que c'était
difficile parce que j'étais parti tu
l'as dit d'être enceinte dans notre voie
là tu as laissé tu as tout laisser
tomber puis quand tu es revenu qu'est ce
qui s'est passé alors d'abord pourquoi
tu es revenu convoité par essentiel
parce que j'ai besoin de travail pour
gagner ma vie je me suis séparée du père
de mon fils nous sommes séparés d'un
commun accord ça arrive donc sur parti
prendre mais micro-jupe bon ok je
commence à 0 on prend le bébé on est à
paris
non ces brouilles et
mon producteur à l'époque fondé sa
compagnie de disques papinou parce que
je vous dis monsieur je vendais sa
maison dit je te fais un petit peu sur
les voies de garage parce qu'elle était
vendue une grosse multinationale et
comme beaucoup de denis garreau qui
chargent sur son prénom on s'est trouvé
quelques artistes impériaux à se
débrouiller recommence à zéro donc j'ai
fait partie de ces moody a dit cependant
tu l'as vécu comment ce changement de
situation c'est à dire ce passage
finalement d'estaing contant les télés
les machins les trucs il d'un seul coup
on vas tu reviens après l'enfant à paris
comment tu l'as vécu ça c'était une
fille solide bien sûr enfin ça a été dur
quand même
ce qui est dur c'est que souvent les
gens moi ce qui me le plus pénible c'est
parce que j'en parle à l'imparfait
oui mais moi je suis fan du futur moi
j'essaie d'avancer de philosophie de bip
le moment présent et surtout de me
donner des visions de visualiser mon
futur sur un an seulement et d'avoir et
de prendre le temps de faire ce que j'ai
à faire c'est pas seulement chanter
souci m'occuper des gens que j'aime et
pouvoir me consacrer parce que quand je
travaille beaucoup les gens que j'aime
et vous voyez jamais donc je vais me
faisait souffrir font déjà l'enfant
maintenant qu'ils nous voient ma grand
mère elle n'est pas morte
enfin presque d'où elle est très âgé et
là avec moi et avec toi tu la préserver
c'est normal chez vous laisse à brière
les montagnards ont gardé vieux la
maison tu as dit
j'avais pas les dents assez longue ça
veut dire que tu étais pas prêtes à tout
donner pour être une énorme star ce que
tu aurais pu être une énorme énorme star
il la voit que tu avais être pourquoi
alors tu mets pas tout sacrifier à quoi
ces sachets flexible parce que la gloire
quand on est en haut de la pyramide cei
a pas beaucoup de tests pour tout le
monde parce que j'avais des rêves 1 doit
faire froid là où parler tout seul du
sol j'ai connu un petit peu ça m'a fait
peur les corrections de ne rien rater de
finale andy tube abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus